[Music]
look
[Music]
all right guys let's actually go right
to joe biden on the crisis involving
russia
and ukraine
from the beginning of this crisis i have
been absolutely clear and consistent
the united states is prepared no matter
what happens
we are ready with diplomacy
to
be engaged in diplomacy with russia
and our allies and partners to improve
stability and security in europe as a
whole
and we are ready to respond decisively
to russian attack on ukraine wow which
is still very much a possibility wow for
all the events of the last few weeks and
months
this has been our approach
it remains our approach now
so today i want to speak to the american
people about the situation on the ground
please the steps we've taken
the actions we're prepared to take
and what's at stake for us and the world
are we going to war how this may impact
on us here at home
for weeks now together with our allies
and partners my administration has
engaged in non-stop diplomacy
this weekend i spoke again with
president putin to make clear that we
are ready to keep pursuing high-level
diplomacy
to reach written understandings among
russia the united states and the nations
of europe to address legitimate security
concerns if that's
his wish
there's security concerns and ours
president putin and i agreed
that our team should continue to engage
toward this end
along with our european allies and
partners
yesterday
the russian government publicly proposed
to continue the diplomacy
i agree
we should give the diplomacy every
chance to succeed
and i believe there are real ways to
address our respective security concerns
the united states has put on the table
concrete ideas to establish a security
environment in europe
we're proposing new arms control
measures
new transparency measures
new strategic stability measures
these measures that apply to all parties
nato and russia alike
we're willing to make practical
result-oriented steps
that can advance our common security
we will not sacrifice basic principles
though
nations have a right to sovereignty and
territorial integrity
they have the freedom to set their own
course
and choose with whom they will associate
but that still leaves plenty room for
diplomacy and for de-escalation let's
hope that's the best way forward for all
parties in our view
we'll continue our diplomatic efforts in
close consultation with our allies and
our partners
as long as there is hope of diplomatic
resolution that prevents the use of
force and avoids incredible human
suffering that would follow we will
pursue it
the russian defense minister reported
today
that some military units are leaving
their positions near ukraine
that would be good
but we have not yet verified that we
have not yet verified the russian
military units are returning to their
home bases
indeed our analysts indicate that they
remain very much in a threatening
position
and the fact remains right now russia
has more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
that's why i've asked
several times that all americans in
ukraine leave now
before it's too late to leave safely wow
it is why we have temporarily relocated
our embassy from kiev
to la vie
in western ukraine
approaching the polish border
that's where my uh ancestors are from
love area and with the world about
russia's plans
and the seriousness of the situation so
that everyone can see for themselves
what is happening
we've shared what we know
and what we're doing about it
let me be equally clear about what we
are not doing
the united states and nato are not a
threat to russia
ukraine is not threatening russia
neither the u.s nor nato have missiles
in ukraine
we do not do not have plans to put them
there as well
we're not targeting the people of russia
we do not seek to destabilize russia
to the citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine whoa a
country and a people with whom you share
such deep ties of family history and
culture
77 years ago our people fought and
sacrificed side by side to end the worst
war in history
world war ii
was a war of necessity
but if russia attacks ukraine it would
be a war of choice
or a war without cause or reason
i say these things not to provoke
but to speak the truth
because the truth matters
accountability matters
if russia does invade in the days and
weeks ahead
the human cost for ukraine will be
immense
and the strategic cross for russia will
also be immense
if russia attacks ukraine
you'll be met with overwhelming
international condemnation
the world will not forget
that russia chose needless death and
destruction
invading ukraine will prove to be a
self-inflicted wound
the united states and our allies and
partners will respond decisively
the west is united and galvanized
today our nato allies
and the alliance is as unified and
determined as it has ever been
and the source of our unbreakable
strength continues to be the power
resilience and universal appeal
of our shared democratic values
because this is about more than just
russia and ukraine
it's about standing for what we believe
in
for the future we want for our world
for liberty for liberty the right
of countless
countries to choose their own destiny
and the right of people to determine
their own futures
for the principle that a country can't
change its neighbors borders by force
that's our vision
and toward that end i'm confident that
vision
that freedom will prevail
if russia proceeds
we will rally the world to oppose its
aggression
the united states and our allies and
partners around the world are ready to
impose powerful sanctions
on export controls including actions
that
did not we did not pursue when russia
invaded crimea in eastern ukraine in
2014.
we put intense pressure
on their largest and most significant
financial institutions and key
industries i guess he's saying it's not
going to go like 2014 with crimea as
soon as if russia moves
we'll impose long-term consequences will
undermine russia's ability to compete
economically and strategically
and when it comes to nordstrom 2 the
pipeline that would bring natural gas
from russia to germany
if russia further invades ukraine it
will not happen wow
while i will not send americans gotta
stick to it in ukraine
we have supplied the ukrainian military
with equipment to help them defend
themselves
we provided training
and advice and intelligence for the same
purpose
and make no mistake
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory
with the full force of american power
remember
not against one nato country's attack
against all of us
the united states commitment to article
5 is sacrosanct
already
in response to russia's build-up of
troops i've sent additional u.s forces
to bolster
nato's eastern flank
several allies have also announced
they'll add forces and capabilities to
ensure deterrence and defense along
nato's eastern flank
we will also continue to conduct
military exercises with our allies and
partners to enhance defensive readiness
and if russia invades
we'll take further steps to reinforce
our presence in nato
reassure itself for our allies and deter
further aggression
to be clear
if russia decides to invade that would
also have consequences here at home
but the american people understand that
defending democracy and liberty is never
without cost wow
this is a cause of the unites
republicans and democrats
and i want to thank the leaders and
members of congress of both parties
who've forcefully spoken out in defense
of our most basic
most bipartisan most american principles
i will not pretend this will be painless
there could be impact on our energy
prices uh-oh
so we are taking active steps to
alleviate the pressure on our own energy
markets and offset raising prices are
markets going to crater these last 20
minutes of trading consumers and
producers
were prepared to deploy all the tools in
authority are disposal to provide relief
at the gas pump
and i'll work with congress on
additional measures help protect
consumers and address the impact of
prices at the pump
we are not seeking direct confrontation
with russia
though i have been clear
that if russia targets americans
in ukraine right here they will respond
forcefully
and if russia attacks the united states
or our allies through asymmetric means
like disruptive cyber attacks against
our companies or critical infrastructure
we are prepared to respond
we're moving in lockstep with our nato
allies and partners to deepen our
collective defense against threats in
cyberspace
two paths are still open
for the sake of historic responsibility
russia and the united states share
for global stability
for the sake of our common future to
choose diplomacy
but let there be no doubt
if russia commits this breach by
invading ukraine responsible nations
around the world will not hesitate to
respond
we do not stand for freedom
where it is at risk today
will surely pay a steeper price tomorrow
thank you i'll keep you informed
mr president
whether or not they are dealing with
ukraine
okay so this is not actually
today's like main event there's a press
briefing starting in 18 minutes and
that's really the main event okay so
stay with us because that is starting
momentarily and at that point there are
going to be all sorts of questions asked
about
um what we just heard and what is
potentially
uh on the table here okay so we're going
to be watching all of that very very
closely i will take this is all live
guys yes we are live i am going to take
your super chats which will pop up on
the screen over there if they are sent
we are going to be
reviewing and looking at so many things
i have so much to catch up on with you
and talk a little bit about the week
ahead and really the couple weeks ahead
this is really now let's
i am gonna try to avoid brain dead takes
on this live stream and if you guys will
permit me to do so i will i will do
everything i can to avoid brain dead
takes so let me first point out the
following
one can simultaneously believe
putin
is the aggressor here and
that we don't want the united states
getting involved and
that we don't want to send troops to
ukraine which biden just said he would
not do
wow
that's that's possible yes
just because you say putin is clearly
the aggressor here
doesn't mean
you are some kind of you know
imperialist or whatever right
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau mccrown
right and the rest of these zio beasts
right
so um you know it's sort of like i've
talked to you guys before about these
people where you go
hey uh
what's happening with the uyghurs in
china that's that's terrible it's
terrible authoritarianism
and someone goes the effort you talking
about the u.s thought about killing
castro in the 60s
what what
yeah and i
would have been against that if i was
alive and i
what am i in some kind of fantasy world
here
hey uh you know
um
i really don't like the way
that the maduro regime
uh uses populist rhetoric but actually
takes all of the spoils available
from uh venezuelan oil and people live
in abject poverty
uh yeah but david do you do you know
what the us tried to do in nicaragua
what
we please guys please guys we're not
we're not gonna do it this is not the
channel for you okay if those are the
takes you want there's probably someone
that'll lately feed it to you
uh it's just not this channel
it's just not this channel okay we're
not gonna we're not gonna do it
all right
uh super chats no none all right very
good we're standing by for a white house
press briefing
certainly questions are going to be
asked about all of this let me just see
here
uh i want to find a backup stream
very very powerful backup stream
um what do we have here
let me filter by live and and i have so
much to talk about guys so please don't
don't think that we're gonna miss any of
it
uh okay i guess this is sort of like the
stream right now
um okay so we're standing by for for the
white house press briefing i want to say
a huge thank you
to guitar goddess stuck a duck jen here
sterling lana and the great nug wrangler
for their twitch prime subscriptions rug
nug wrangler now 29 consecutive months
also thanks to the sarcasm fairy for the
twitch prime subscription and lastly a
huge thank you to marvin giles who just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
and remember you can use the coupon code
obama obama on my website to sign up at
an ungodly discount i mean just
absolutely ungodly
what is being uh what is being offered
there okay let's get to some other
things because i i just have so so much
uh to talk about um let's do the dave
ramsey thing okay i've told you guys
some of you guys have gotten pulled in
by dave ramsey into thinking that
uh he's someone to listen to on
financial advice my position on dave
ramsey has been
he will sometimes stumble across
completely uncontroversial and
reasonable financial advice but it's all
wrapped up in
cuckoo christianity and here's an
example that was sent to me of why dave
ramsey is not a guy to get financial
advice from um and so this thing from
the
communist and socialist college
professors that have taught everyone
that capitalism is easy check please i'm
i'm out that's it i mean that's enough
that's enough you know go to someone
else guys go to someone else but we'll
listen to a little bit more evil has got
to stop
because it's accurate it's inaccurate
biblically it's an accurate in truth
there are wonderful companies that are
for-profit to do a great job again not
saying
that there's anything wrong with doing a
not for profit
i've got a good friend uh craig groschel
bobby grunwald over at life church they
obviously life church is a non-profit
and they have the largest
bible app one of the largest apps of all
of apple oh my god everyone's got it now
let me give you guys an alternative now
i'm going to make something i'm going to
make something really clear here okay
if you're interested in content
that is related to finance and business
and has a different religious bent like
okay so i know a lot of you want your
financial advice
without religious elements and i can
recommend to you
endless newsletters i mean get yourself
on
uh hold on let me actually look here
uh
get yourself on barry ritholtz's
newsletter
get yourself on
nick majuli's newsletter
get yourself on ben carson's news
there's so many economics and finance
newsletters that are really really great
great great stuff
but i also want to say if you like the
approach of mixing the personal finance
and business stuff with religion
i have an alternative channel for you
which i think is endlessly superior to
dave ramsey now some of you are going to
say well david of course of course
you're you're jewish so of course you
could recommend this
i'm an atheist jew okay for me
orthodox judaism doesn't really give me
anything but there's actually a
legitimately
good channel called um uh living lachaim
that does really interesting interviews
this it's it's openly an orthodox jewish
channel
okay
and
endlessly fascinating content they just
did this stream with andrew singer who
uh is a fortune 100 executive
check check this out this is this is
actually really interesting stuff i'll
just give you like 30 seconds okay his
suggestion um and i have my people use
this is something of the following so
this is like this is on on job interview
techniques and it's fantastic something
that usually said
just got off the trader's update
very interesting mention of your market
call me or
just ended with traders
something very important about your
account these are actually sales
techniques please take a look or
something like that it's something that
basically is very immediate
very real it has to be real
and take somebody attend somebody's
attention because it hits them
financially so in my business people buy
electricity the price of electricity
changes all the time people come in
anyway i'm not going to bore you guys
with this but my point is
if you said to me hey david can you
recommend a religiously oriented finance
and economics channel on youtube
even in that category it's not dave
ramsey it's not dave ramsey the stuff on
this channel is absolutely fantastic the
other episode that's really interesting
on this channel
actually i'm not even gonna i can't even
find it okay it doesn't doesn't even
matter but the whole point is
the dave ramsey stuff it's very bad it's
very very bad and there's really
interesting uh resources and other
things that um that people can look at
okay
um
let me see what else where do i want to
go next did i miss any super chats no
sadly no super chats today
a lot of people are very very close to
getting banned i want to say thanks to
tinda seldarine
and al e
for the twitch prime subscriptions thank
you very much uh truly truly appreciate
that i have so many voicemails for you
guys i have a new voicemail character
um this is a guy who is leaving
weaponized voicemail after weaponized
voicemail i'm just gonna play one for
you but this is a new guy
and just take a listen
david pac-man this is billy harrison
again one of your uh
as you uh
said i was the
most chaotic caller because you heard a
child
cooing a four-month-old child cooing in
the background and a two-year-old
playing with his remote control car
yeah that's real chaotic
but as we call it that's life
normal
but anyways
i want you to play this voicemail clip
on there right i'm doing i mean this i'm
not trying to be rude or anything but
why
are people on the left
so
stupid right stupid stupid
i mean
explain it right
y'all can't debunk anything that donald
trump says
y'all can't present real facts
all y'all do is point out well he he
pronounced that word wrong or he didn't
put a comma here when he was supposed to
put a comma there and this at the third
line point out stupid [ __ ] right yes uh
trump flushing documents down a toilet
and it getting clogged because he's
flushing so many documents that's like a
technicality that's equivalent to a
comma
it's very very you know it's
petty instead of
actual you know
[ __ ] that's worth talking about like
i mean
i was watching okay anyway um that's
fine that's fine a shade williams says
here so you no longer have to say no
super chats today thank you very much
and let me even adjust that there we go
i appreciate that it was getting very
sad from the standpoint of super chats
all right we're going to get back to the
voicemails because because i have so
many other things to talk about with you
guys i have a new
song but i have it only via audio
william j did this what i want to ask
you guys is if anybody wants to make a
video element to this
um i will send you the track now please
if you want the audio track to make a
video remix of this
email info davidpakman.com don't just
email us asking for the track if you
don't really plan to do a video because
it's just our email box is gonna get
flooded
here is the audio that was submitted i
think this would be great for someone to
actually do a music video here is the
new song this is called
elements of bathrooms
toilets
and shelves and bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet right
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
the big massive
[Music]
anyway you guys get the idea so
that is ripe for a music video
um and if if anybody wants the original
high quality audio please email info
davidpakman.com and we will get it to
you okay poustain pete says david sir
the fbi just raided my home zero
evidence it wasn't because i used your
coupon code please advise i'd get a
lawyer
fool in the rain says david i sent one
please check again thank you
lady lobotomy says elements of bathrooms
yes
that is really quite a song
really really quite a song okay so we've
gotten that
uh let's see what else i have here for
everybody oh anthony weiner was on
hannity last night alongside curtis
sliwa
and
hannity asked weiner whether he changed
after serving time
and hannity doesn't really seem to like
weiner's answer it's all very strange
i guess the first question that i have
is you pled guilty anthony
to
sending obscene materials to a young
girl 15 year old girl you went you pled
guilty right you served jail time
have you changed are you a different
person
well um
i think so i don't think anyone can go
through that kind of experience and i
think this is probably true of people
who have
been through other types of adversity i
don't think you go through that type of
experience and don't emerge changed well
that's something
wait a minute so i think it's fairly
happiness that's an obscure answer i
think so
either you know in your heart if you
changed or you know in your heart if you
didn't change right
or do you can you assure people because
you're going to like why does it matter
now try and draw in an audience
and they're going to want he just has a
radio show does it really matter i mean
you know if you've changed or not
have you changed
they they
they can judge for themselves
i'm sorry
i said they can judge for themselves i'm
not out to persuade you or anyone else
that i've changed i mean i i'm doing a
radio show and people can call in and
ask me questions yeah i mean it's like
you know you're not uh he's not teaching
your kids you know it's it's like
okay i mean if you don't then don't
listen to the show i don't know he's
just doing a radio show that's all did
one this past saturday where people had
an opportunity to call in and
where curtis asked me a bunch of
questions and i asked and answer the
best i can but in terms of like i'm
trying to draw someone no i'm not trying
to make someone
like me or someone be persuaded of any
particular outlook on me
we're going to have some conversations
about things going on in new york city
and other places and hopefully people
will tune into the show but i'm not
terribly interested in trying to make
them feel any differently about me yeah
it's like it's all very weird it's like
dude hannity what are you talking about
man
it's all very strange
um we are heading rapidly towards joe
biden's state of the union union address
that's going to be on march 1st i am
really looking forward to
you all joining me for that we will be
live one hour before the state of the
union address that is now in exactly two
weeks we'll be streaming i am looking
very strongly at doing biden bingo i
think uh on if you have ideas for biden
bingo you can email them in i think
we're we'll definitely have not a joke
on there uh maybe malarkey would be on
there give me a break would probably be
there
uh probably that throat clearing he does
will be on there as well whispering will
be on there the term folks
jack
a story about um
you know what is like quoting his dad
would probably be on there he'll often
go like you know my dad used to say joey
uh
how many how many uh you know i don't
even know uh so it'll be biden we'll
have biden bingo i look forward to
everybody joining me on march 1st that's
going to be good
um i do want to say thank you to
sorceress supreme who just signed up on
my website joinpackman.com
with the coupon code obama
and his new member number 10 today
uh grab those memberships
joinpakman.com is the place to do it um
people wanting one more
whatever this guy's name is billy graham
or something like that voicemail here
i'll play one more for you let's listen
this guy's calling almost as frequently
as uh whitney now david pagman
again billy harrison
like i said man
i think that was some
that was some [ __ ] basically some
democratic [ __ ]
call somebody
kids
because they're cooing and laughing and
talking
man i don't even know what he's talking
about
that's that's delusional
yeah i have no clue what he's talking
about benjamin says via super chat david
sir
will you flee the country after a
massive dump of democracy just kidding
love the show keep it up yeah biggest
mistake i've made on the show is and do
you guys know about this someone called
in and just said like hey david
if you ever decided to leave the country
where would you go that was that was the
question just like if you if you
if you decided that where would you go
and it led to about three weeks of me
being called a jew traitor who was going
to take my capital and loyalties
elsewhere
um
it was
nuts just crazy from just like hey like
if you left where would you go man and
we will ban
men yeah well well if that happened we
would be looking at it very closely okay
um a couple of people it came to my
attention through something i posted on
twitter
that many of you are not familiar with
i'm not gay no more
this is one of the most viral
memetic elements in the history of
political media
i'm going to play it for you so
everybody becomes familiar with it the
story here is from a
um from a church a christian church of
some kind where a guy proclaimed
that he was no longer gay thanks to god
and it was like just a it's a crazy
thing you just have to see it to believe
it this is it
break every yoke
he's delivering you now
whatever it is this is the best you need
god to do
he just told you it's done right now
what did you come here for what did you
come down here for tell me to get
delivered more
get delivered
do you believe that the lord tonight has
set you free yes sir
turn around and tell those people this
is the best
i'm not gay no more i am deliberate
turns out he's still gay he later did an
interview with jimmy kimmel and he's
like i'm gay i'm gay
i don't like men no more
i thought i like women
the destructive power of the church i
say women
i'm not gay
i would not date a man
i would not carry a purse i would not
one of my favorite things of the video
is the guys in suits in the background
high-fiving and slapping each other on
the back as this is going on makeup
i will
i will
love
a woman
now listen what
y'all praise god with him hold on wait a
minute
hold just one minute
now either you gonna believe this stuff
or you ought to stop preaching it yes i
do not believe it the guy is gay he
later said i'm gay i'm not dating any
women
if you can't praise god with him you're
an unbeliever right let somebody believe
god with him
[Music]
really like a second line sort of uh
drumming feel there
new orleans style
condemnation
we preach reconciliation
this is a celebration that the guy's not
gay anymore if you can understand the
incredible healing power of this church
[Music]
this place is tax tax-exempt by the way
you guys know that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on right i got a problem here yeah
we no problem i got to get out of here
cause i got to get up early too and put
that long robe on
i got a problem though
it still looks like he's alone
well that's not the only issue you're
going to have in a few a few days later
it turns out
and whether you know it or not the devil
ain't going to leave him alone
i wish i have some shown up believers
that'll come down here and dance with
him and tell him you can do it in the
name of jesus
he's like now that this guy has
announced i've cured him of being gay
please send men to dance with him to the
front of the church
not that there's anything wrong with
that obviously
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right
quite a celebration of heterosexuality
as you can see
[Music]
okay anyway so that guy is no longer gay
but a few days later he was on with
jimmy kimmel and he was like i'm gay i'm
i'm a gay guy
that was that was it
didn't didn't make any sense
meg says david sir your sarcastic
terrorism against the right is one of
the few bright spots in this capitalist
hellscape
keep up the good work thank you meg
i don't totally know what you mean but i
really appreciate it it's a very nice
message thank you uh we're standing by
for jen saki here a couple of other
things for you guys here is dave rubin
who is jewish nominally at least
comparing the unvaccinated to the way
the jews were seen in the lead-up to the
holocaust
this is some people are like oh well you
know
he would know because he's jewish no no
it makes it all the more gross here's
dave rubin i i just said to my guys as
we were playing this it's truly
incredible watching these people flip
the story and how they reverse
everything they say about one thing when
it's their guys doing it versus how
they say it when it's the other guys
doing it first off i just want to say
something very very clearly here please
um i lost family members on both sides
of the holocaust okay i grew up around
holocaust survive
what does that mean on both sides of the
holocaust that's weird
i am well versed in what the holocaust
was and what the demonization of people
is
um although
the guy who was interviewed there and by
the way great cherry-picking on that
daily show and then they they
cherry-pick that on the daily show
and then of course they throw that to
cnn because they're all in on it
together i believe they're both owned by
viacom it's a big conspiracy that's one
big circle jerk in essence um
just for regardless of what the guy said
whether whether you think he said it in
a butchered way or or he shouldn't say
it or something like that
the way something like the holocaust
starts is you otherwise people right you
keep otherwise otherwising them you say
oh you can't be part of the economy you
can't own a store you can't do this
we're going to demonize you you're
diseased
so it is not a giant leap okay it really
is not and i don't care how much hate i
get for this it is not a giant leap
after two years of demonizing certain
people who wanted choice medical choice
and choice used to be thought of as a
good thing um to compare them to the
jews before the holocaust oh my god i
think that his i think he has mayonnaise
in his brain
um you know the funny thing about this
is all of this is based on fears of a
slippery slope it it's a fun one of the
key we're actually going to be speaking
with seth moscowitz seth mosk i told you
guys about this great article about i
think it's called the reactionary trap
hold on the reactionary trap seth
moscowitz yeah here it is
um
i would i could not recommend an article
to you more highly than this article
here by seth moscow it's called the
reactionary trap and it explains
reactionary tendencies on the on the
right and on the left
and one of the fundamental things about
this reactionary movement we're not
missing gensake so everybody relax
one of the big things is
you you have to sow fear
and one of the easiest ways to sow fear
is to make people afraid of slippery
slopes well this is this first step and
then it's going to be this and then it's
going to be this and then it's going to
be this
it has not happened with the vaccines i
mean go back to the first vaccine
requirements
1903 1905 cambridge massachusetts and
they were saying then the next thing you
know and it's and it and it never
happened it's been 119 years and then
there were just vaccine requirements for
other vaccines and then for other
vaccines and there was no slippery slope
in the middle of it for completely
unrelated reasons in germany you had
hitler and it has nothing to do with
vaccine mandates and this is how they
prey on people and there is it's a very
effective rhetorical tool to pull people
into into this reactionary fear-based
thinking to talk about slippery slopes
when there are none
and many things have gotten worse in the
united states over time right the
slippery slope of cutting taxes on the
rich has led to record inequality that's
real
that's a real slippery slope um
but uh this this is just nonsense and
you know the fact that reuben is jewish
doesn't make him any more credible it
makes this all the more sad
some private businesses saying you gotta
be vaccinated or you got to be
vaccinated to come over the border or
whatever that is nothing like the
holocaust it is nothing like the jews
before the holocaust nothing nothing
um and it's completely irresponsible
that uh reuben is doing this i want to
say thank you to mark pittman mark just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama obama and his new member
number 11
i would love it if you signed up on my
website you can use that same coupon
code obama also a great day to re-up
your twitch prime subscriptions if you
have amazon prime you can do that for
free the article is called the
reactionary trap here's the article just
just search for the reactionary trap
seth moscow it's it's not a very long
read
and it is very very good really and he's
going to be on the show he's traveling
right now but we're going to have him on
in april to talk about the the article
and the entire concept okay a check on
the markets
uh no they they did okay markets
collapsed a little right when biden
started speaking it was this little dip
but it ended up with sort of like a nice
day and that's it we don't have to
follow the markets too too much day to
day but that gets us
um
that gets us out of the way with that
uh okay we played the voicemail
that we had
um let me continue on with a couple of
other things oh no this we already did
okay next
uh mike pillow has really been having a
tough go of it number one his bank
canceled him for reputational risk
they canceled him he lost his bank
two
he went on a very strange rant on
lindell tv a few days ago about how fox
he's gonna try to hack fox now i guess
it's very weird take a look at this
controls it around my facebook and they
go there's no evidence mike give it up
um just go over to lindell tv and go to
the number lindelt tv too like he's
completely disheveled i mean it's just
everything about this video is bizarre
and you're gonna see garland on there
pouring out the evidence from georgia
and then you know it won't be funny
because then he doesn't look so sober
but i guess he is sober supposedly when
fox says we're all american when he when
fox calls the united states of america
all the people liars and our great
president donald trump a liar we say
well fox
here why don't you run this tape on your
show instead of sean hannity and run it
and then watch the stuff come out you
know then maybe we should get anybody
understanding what he's talking about
here anybody know
sort of like a god bless
the united sheish moment do i even have
that let me see here
and god bless
the united states our cyber guys brandon
that looked at all the evidence to hook
up our stream to foxes you know like
he's got they're gonna he and sean
hannity are gonna be crossing streams
hooking them up like they all attack
they all attack glendale tv all the time
we can attack can you imagine this is
sean hannity all of a sudden breaking
news right out of georgia we can't even
put the the evidence pouring in to
pouring in arizona pouring in wisconsin
and fox would you'd have the murdoch's
going oh no what are we gonna do the
truth is how we're the liars pretty sick
guy right i mean it's like
very very strange stuff
uh then here's another report from
earlier today apparently pillow is
sending pillows to the truckers in
canada and there's some issue there as
well liz uh you've got a live shot of
what it looks like here at port
huron here in uh michigan this is one of
the entry points to canada and you've
got this big 53 foot my pillow truck all
loaded up with about 10 000 pillows
uh just awaiting uh the permits to cross
over this bridge let me pan the camera
over to our left your right you'll see
the entry point that guy just snort that
was weird uh the permits to cross over
this bridge let me pan the camera over
to our left
sound like a pig snort there for a
second that was a weird noise
right you'll see the entry point right
there uh
the blue truck there you can see it uh
generally it takes only if just a few
seconds really as the trucks pull up
they give the paperwork the paperwork's
given back to them and they're on their
way now we've been out here for a couple
hours uh just kind of watching the
traffic across it all right so
apparently a pillow truck having issues
and then here he was yesterday on the
steve bannon show
tell me if you can understand what he's
talking about here
well arizona you know that was a god
what about over a week ago now they uh
they've got quite a few representatives
and um uh senators that signed on we're
getting more and more every day i was in
wisconsin and
all they need there we i was over there
with a great tim rampant a uh he is a
senator that put the bill before to
uh has it ready to decertify wisconsin
now you guys know that decertification
isn't a thing right do people in the
audience understand this whole
they're getting ready to decertify
from 15 months ago like the there's
about three different layers here first
of all
there is no such decertification process
number one number two
even if a state invented a
decertification and like called
washington dc and was like hey we've
decertified
there's no process for
taking away electoral votes 15 months i
mean there's just no process for that
you guys know that i'm sure it was an
amazing event i was there five hours i
planned on being there for a half hour
but there's wisconsin there all over
wisconsin go hey we have the evidence
let's get this de-certified i met some
other senators and representatives steve
they're they're this close to getting on
board they all
i believe we can get them all to jump on
together because a lot of them still
live in fear they're going you know fear
or they're not they were very
very um a lot of ed kids just to be
educated on this that a lot of them said
well there's nothing that can be done
anyway right absolutely there can be
done that we've got lawyers
constitutional lawyers look at this
three of these states you you decertify
and then it goes back to all the states
and uh and it votes one person or one
state one vote no that's not that that
literally doesn't happen there is no
decertification process and even if you
did
nothing happens there's there's no
process for that can you imagine imagine
if california calls and goes hey we're
decertifying and then they go oh cancel
the election we'll do one state one vote
uh and each state gets to get
of course not of course not and there's
it's republican controlled so this is
very real and it's come it's manifesting
it's coming to fruition
and it's gonna happen steve i will not
quit until we get this done okay here's
my question to you guys how many of you
think pillow believes what he's saying
is he serious or is he not
i'm starting to wonder whether he could
really believe this crap because it does
not
who could really believe this
wow a lot of you guys say he's serious
that's wild
that's really scary
yeah let's do a poll okay
let me set this up one at a time first
let me do the one on twitch
does mike pillow really believe
his decertification
nonsense
and the answers will be yes or no so
we'll start that
and then we'll do it on youtube as well
yes no
as we stand by here for jen saki
let's see over on twitch
wow 75 of you believe he really does
believe it now almost 80 percent
uh over on youtube
about 75 as well no okay i i just i
really can't tell at this point i really
can't tell
it's
it's truly bizarre
um
still about 80 percent on twitch
75 on youtube yeah
it's so it's i know it's it's very
difficult to tell thank you to
chronically steph as well as drush for
the twitch prime subscriptions numbers
12 and 13. also thank you and welcome to
pablo lujan
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code obama obama really
really appreciate that
um yeah i'll i'll open phone lines if we
get to a hundred um re-up your twitch
prime subscriptions sign up on my
website join pacman.com we'll open phone
lines after gen saki and i'll speak to
some of you oh also thanks to sterling's
kitchen
for the twitch prime subscription
very very good we have started oh how is
rumble going yeah that's a that's a
really good question actually hold on
let's take a look at that as many of you
know we are now on the right wing
platform rumble we got our first
736 subscribers
um it's funny because most of the people
commenting are our viewers leaving like
trolling comments
oh hi everyone here we go
okay um i have two items for all of you
at the top uh two we today we have uh
some exciting updates on our competition
agenda first we have uh progress on our
administration's effort to lower the
price of internet for millions of
americans i believe there are people who
once lived in apartments or still do in
this room who will love this if you
haven't already seen it i love it today
the fcc announced important steps to
increase competition in the market for
high-speed internet which president
biden requested in his executive order
on competition as some of you may know
the landlord if you live in an apartment
sometimes requires you to purchase
internet service from one source and
today the fcc voted on a bipartisan
unanimous basis to crack down on
exclusivity agreements between landlords
and internet providers known as
sweetheart deals which lock tenants and
apartments and office buildings into
just one option for internet that might
be good for the landlord
and for the internet service provider
but bad for tenants bad for american the
american people bad for people living in
apartment buildings who may have to pay
more and accept lower quality service
more than a third of americans live in
apartments and condos and many
businesses operate in multi-tenant
buildings like office buildings or malls
so this is a sweeping problem the fcc is
starting to fix today and second a
competition update that is relevant for
our national security today the
department of defense released a new
report
required by the president's competition
executive order explaining that new
actions to promote competition in
defense contracting this report details
that since the 1990s the number of
aerospace and defense prime contractors
has shrunk from 51 to just five that
consolidation means taxpayers have to
pay more for defense services and it
threatens our national security
strengthened merger oversight is one of
the five actions the defense department
is taking to address the problem we've
already seen concrete progress on that
front this week on sunday the fdc
successfully blocked lockheed martin's 4
billion attempt to acquire aerojet a
proposed mega merger of major defense
suppliers the ftc had filed a lawsuit
explaining that the merger would jack up
the price the us government has to pay
while delivering lower quality and less
innovation also wanted to note last last
item from me at the top is we're
thrilled the senate did its job today
and confirmed the renowned clinical
trialist dr robert kelf once again to
the job of fda commissioner and once
again on a bipartisan basis he brings to
this critical post a lifetime of
knowledge and the institutional
experience that will ensure he hits the
ground running and is guided by the
science on critical missions facing the
fda from continuing to lead the fight
against covid19 to combating the opioid
crisis to ensuring safety of our
nation's food supply
uh someone's telling me destiny recently
called me racist if if anyone can email
that clip to info davidpakman.com if
it's real we'll look at it after this
gasoline prices are up 20 cents a gallon
over the last 30 days on average
is the president saying that if people
are paying more at the pump that is
essentially a direct result of vladimir
putin's actions
and he is to blame for the current birth
we've seen at higher prices well the
president wasn't making a market
assessment or how the market moves what
he was conveying very very clearly to
the american public is that if russia
too were to invade and we were to put in
place crippling sanctions that would
have consequences or an impact here at
home so i know that wasn't exactly how
you were asking the question but that
was what he was conveying in his answer
in terms of the price of gasoline what
we've seen is we know back in december
it went down by about 10 cents thanks to
tapping the strategic petroleum reserve
something where there's still releases
that have been ongoing the president
also made clear in his remarks that he
is open to
all options or on the table to help
bring down the price of gasoline but he
wasn't making a market assessment he was
just making clear to the public that if
russia invades and we put in place
crippling sanctions that would have an
impact on the public and then secondly
on ukraine the president talked about
diplomatic efforts yeah did you go into
more detail on what those diplomatic
efforts could be is this going to be
more u.s interaction could there be a
face-to-face meeting with putin
and then how would you define success
under diplomacy is it as simple as
no invasion or are there broader rules
you're looking for given that everything
is now on the table or more things are
on the table uh sure well on the first
part you may have seen or not that our
secretary of state spoke with foreign
minister lavrov earlier today the
president spoke with president macron
earlier today as well i think the
readout just went out to all of you or
it should be in your inboxes as well and
what he means by ongoing diplomacy is
that it will continue
at the pace and urgency that you have
seen from him over the last several
weeks and from his team and it is some
of it will come from the president some
will come from high-level members of his
national security team
and some of it will come from our
european partners or nato allies who we
remain in very close contact with in
terms of engagement with president putin
uh you as you know he spoke with him on
saturday and he believes in the power of
a leader to leader diplomacy but i don't
have a prediction of a next engagement
at this point in time and what about oh
sorry my success i wanted sorry i didn't
get to that last part of your question
um you know how the we define success is
i think how a lot of our european
partners and nato allies would define it
which would be an a de-escalation
a proven de-escalation at the border
of ukraine uh where the russians are
pulling back their troops uh where they
are making clear to all to the global
community to the media to the public uh
that they are not invading ukraine and
backing that up with actions
i think following up on on this energy
question in terms of the impact on our
energy which the president mentioned and
then the consequences
what should americans be prepared for
yes many of you pointing out dc is
dropping their indoor mask mandate soon
i don't know how that will affect the
press briefing room going on um
was the fact that um if russia decides
to invade there could be consequences
here at home
and that could have an impact on energy
prices which could have an impact on
prices at the gas pump um and we're
taking while we're taking active steps
to alleviate the pressure on our own
energy markets and every option is on
the table to offset rising prices as you
saw the president act last fall
range of options remain on the table he
also wanted to be very clear and direct
with the american people about what the
impact could be and the fact that in his
view defending democracy and liberty is
never without cost but we need to convey
to the american people exactly what that
could look like one more on russia if
president putin decides not to invade
does president biden consider that a
victory
i think the world the global community
would consider that a victory but again
i think what the president's view is and
what the national security team's view
is is that this is ultimately up to
president putin and every step we've
taken up to date over the last weeks and
even months to coordinate with our nato
allies to stay in lock in close touch
with leaders in congress and members
about what our plans are to put together
a um a crippling sanctions package what
we are doing is we're presenting the
choice to president putin he ultimately
is going to decide which path he chooses
go ahead um i just wanted to close the
loop on um a few things so the the
ukraine has been experiencing a number
of cyber attacks today um
a number of its banks were affected the
defense ministry was affected
has the united states attributed those
attacks to russia
i don't have anything on the attribution
at this point in time i know there have
been a range of reports
what i can say is that
we have been
in touch with ukrainians
our allies and partners
working with them to deter and respond
to malicious cyber activity we have also
been warning for weeks and months both
publicly and in our engagements with the
ukrainians as well as our european
partners about the potential for russia
to conduct cyber operations in ukraine
but i don't have anything more specific
on attribution at this point okay and
just you know kind of moving a little
bit into the realm of the hypothetical
there are a lot of steps oh boy i know
there are a lot of steps that russia
could take that are short of an invasion
but that are still
um you know aggressive um you know
including cyber including um there's
this
uh stuff that their congress has taken
on recognizing these breakaway regions
in ukraine i wore one of these duckbill
masks the other day it was handed to me
i could barely get it over my head you
see that double strap i had such
technical trouble with it it's like that
with sanctions as you would to you know
an actual invasion
we have conveyed before and i'll
reiterate now that we would be prepared
to respond
with a range of malicious activities or
actions that the russians were to take
okay then one more thing i know that um
i guess the point of it is that it kind
of like it doesn't it doesn't move when
you talk so it's like good for talking
the german chancellor said today that
ukraine joining nato is simply not on
the table it's not on an agenda item
right now is that how you would
characterize it from from the white
house well i think as you've heard the
president convene you just heard him
convey in his remarks uh our view from
the united states is that nations have
the right to sovereignty to territorial
integrity freedom to set their own
course and choose who they associate
with so we the united states we're never
going to pressure ukraine or any country
to join or not join
a global alliance that is up to them and
up to the uh other members of nato
go ahead uh thanks jen just you say all
options are on the table let's be more
specific on the possibility of a gas tax
holiday would the white house support
doing that
i have nothing to predict for you at
this point but all options remain on the
table he said in his speech
if russia attacks americans in ukraine
we will respond is there specific
intelligence suggesting that some kind
of targeted attack on americans in
ukraine
i don't think he was suggesting that i
think as we've conveyed as we've warned
uh and been very clear about the risk
that would be posed to anyone who's in
ukraine including american citizens were
russia to invade one of the biggest
militaries in the world that there would
be serious risks to civilians that's i
think what he was conveying and with the
ukrainian president slated to be out of
his country this weekend in the munich
security conference
you guys think that's a good idea for
him to be gone right now
i don't think we have an assessment on
that from here uh obviously the munich
security conference is an opportunity
for any leader to uh engage with
communicate with
other leaders in the world and obviously
the vice president is going as you know
he's got a busy day obviously with
ukraine but has the president talked to
any supreme court nominee have any
interviews been scheduled will they
disappoint you here ed um and just
convey that i think we're not going to
give day-to-day updates uh from here uh
moving forward about whether or not he's
done interviews
what i can confirm for you is we're
still on track to
for the president to make a decision and
make an announcement uh before the end
of the month which is good in two weeks
he will do some interviews in the next
two weeks that's what i can confirm for
you go ahead jackie thanks jeff um
we've been told for a long time that
some cyber attacks would likely precede
an invasion um so if it turns out that
russia is behind what happened today
um or is i guess how i should phrase it
is is there work being done
quickly to figure out if russia is
behind what happened today so that
sanctions can be imposed before there is
bloodshed where is the calculus still
sort of centering on
uh force on force or some you know
passing over they
sure well we are constantly doing those
assessments and certainly as any cyber
attack happens that is certainly a
process that happens uh behind the
scenes and that our intelligence
community and our national security
community undertakes as it would be in
this case as well i would note though as
it relates to sanctions one there's a
range of means uh that we could uh
respond uh both seen and unseen so it's
a cyber attack or any other attack and
the president has the purview to do uh
whatever he chooses in that regard but
our view remains that uh the crippling
package of sanctions is an effective
deterrent so if you do that all in
advance
what is to stop them from
moving forward now that may have to be a
different of policy issue a different uh
opinion i should say on policy issues
with uh some in congress and that's okay
but that is our view from the
administration there and then this may
or may not be related at all but is
there any information on what caused the
power outage on the north lawn i mean
every tv network lost power at the same
time during a very inconvenient time i
will just note for all of you and for us
um i don't have any assessment of that
no or yes
does the white house view um ukraine
giving up on nato aspirations as a
possible op-ramp i understand that you
know the president has said the
administration has said over and over
that you know nato members would not um
you know encourage or would not would
not give up that ability uh
for someone else to join but you know
they do have a long way to go
and now that there is you know all of
this concern that if there was a member
if they did become members it could
potentially trigger article five is
there any discussion
um among nato allies about you know
how significant it would be if zielinski
were to
make that offer himself
well we have not raised that um from the
united states um and again i would
reiterate what i said a little bit
earlier which is that our position is
that we are not going to pressure
ukraine or any country to join or not
join
an alliance that it is uh nations have
the right to sovereignty and territorial
integrity and uh that's a choice for
them to make
why is the administration
encouraging americans who are evacuated
fleeing through poland um to be
to bring proof of coven 19 vaccination
as i understand it poland does not
require that so is there going to be
a shift in messaging
for americans who are trying to get out
through poland i would check with the
state department on that i'm happy to
follow up with you for you on your
behalf as well go ahead
thank you so much to i want to circle
back to the idea of what de-escalation
would look like and how the
administration would trust that it were
actually real do you have a sense of how
many troops you would need to actually
see with your own eyes through satellite
images or otherwise would need to
withdraw in order for this
administration to feel as though putin
were in fact escalating well i think
kristin that is a decision that we would
make in partnership with our
nato allies right and european countries
and you look at everything from
satellite imagery something that many of
you have
access to uh to validation and
verification of what they're saying they
would do so i i can't i'm not go and i'm
not going to be in a position nor do you
know what i expect the defense
department would be to give you a troop
number but i think it will would be very
clear if that were a step they were
taking okay and i think there have been
a lot of mixed messages publicly coming
out today
among them the nato secretary general
said that there is cause for cautious
optimism when it comes to some of these
talks that are happening behind the
scenes does the administration does the
president share that cautious optimism
because we heard from the president very
firm language
well the president also conveyed it
would be positive if it was verified
that they pulled back their troops and
certainly the openness to diplomacy is
something that
everybody should support and i think our
nato allies would support as well at the
same time we've seen this playbook
before and especially given uh the
history of president putin and the
russians their their their history of
false flag operations of misinformation
we need to verify so and i guess that's
my question does the administration
share the nato secretary general's
cautious optimism
i think i'm not gonna i don't think we
need to put in more words than what the
president just conveyed in a speech to
the country
gop senators have unveiled a sanctions
bill
um
have you assessed whether or not this is
something the administration wants to
see some movement on is this something
that you
would potentially support given that the
bipartisan talks stalled
not yet because it just came out uh but
again our view remains that a bipartisan
effort would be the best effort moving
forward and as i conveyed to jackie a
few minutes ago you know our view
continues to be that the crippling
sanctions package we've designed is
meant to be deterrent
thank you go ahead jen uh the senate's
working on this stopgap funding bill you
know the deadline is friday
what's the level of confidence that
the president be able to sign that
extension in by friday and separately
has the administration been talking to
the two republican senators who've uh
raised concerns senator brock
lee and blackburn
we are engaged with a range of democrats
and republicans and certainly uh we are
hopeful that we will be able to sign
this um i would note though that i
believe and correct me if i'm wrong here
that one of senator blackburn's primary
concerns is about uh a relation to the
set to the funding of crack pipes is
this correct
which is not an issue so this is a this
is an issue that what is happening here
is that the potential to hold up funding
the government and important programs
around an issue that is not an issue
because we've been very clear that we
are not providing funding for crack
pipes oh and then the senate banking
committee had planned i don't know fox
news did 24 hours on crack pipes it
seemed pretty real there was a hold up
there republicans have objected to
sarah bloom raskin's nomination
what does the administration think of
this delay
and is the administration going to
provide any additional details to
senator toomey some of the issues that
he's raised
well let me first say that this is in a
very extreme step that's totally
irresponsible in our view it's never
been more important to have confirmed
leadership at the fed to help continue
our recovery and fight inflation and
obviously they have a
unique role to play an important vital
role to play as it relates to inflation
and i think democrats and republicans
have agreed on that for decades so
republicans are out there saying
inflation's a problem it's a huge issue
we agree and then they're not even
bothering to show up to even vote
against these nominees to the federal
reserve what message is that sending to
the american public so uh we and i would
note just on sarah bloom raskin since
you asked me about her as well and she's
one of the most qualified individuals to
ever be nominated to the federal reserve
she's made the strongest ethics
commitments in the history of the fed
even as she's made extensive disclosures
to the banking committee as a natural
part of the process senator toomey has
continued to promote false allegations
that have already been shot down by
ethics experts the kansas city fed the
founder of the reserve trust and sarah
bloomraskin herself so we're going to
continue to work with chairman brown on
a path forward and look forward to the
banking committee eventually holding a
vote to commit these uh to confirm these
five nominees
is there any entertaining of other
options if it stalls in committee you
know this appears to be some question
about whether the senate as a whole can
advance these nominations is that
something you're exploring or is that
something that you don't think you have
the power to do
we are you mean in terms of different
legislative processes or different
speculation that the
full senate could uh sort of skip the
committee vote if it stalls out and
bring them forward sure
do you believe that the senate has that
power award you have does it have food
through committee our focus right now is
on working with chairman brown on on uh
moving these nominees through the
committee
can i ask
[ __ ] hhs briefed congress uh this
week uh reporting with 30 billion in
funding can you give a defensive aid
from that be what in particular do you
need this ton of coughing in the press
room today
sure so um
hs justice briefing uh today or this
afternoon was a part of our regular
conversations with congress about
various resources needs including uh
what is needed for coveted response
this is important because while we
continue to have sufficient funds to
respond to the current omicron surge in
the coming weeks
our goal has always been to ensure that
we are well prepared to stay ahead of
the virus so we've been in these ongoing
conversations about what those needs
might look like and this was a part of
that effort in terms of funds that have
been allocated or spent more than 90
percent so available rescue plan funds
which is where the funding has come from
to date have been obligated or allocated
90 of that has been for purchases of
vaccines and therapeutics vaccine
distribution efforts that have gotten
shots and arms testing including for
schools and at other high need locations
resources from the rescue feeling and
prior code response bills have enabled
us to respond forcefully to the delta
and omicron surges and what we're trying
to do now is uh stay ahead uh and and
stay in in contact with congress about
what those needs might look like
secretary lincoln said yesterday that
the u.s is not on pace right now to meet
the president's goal of whl goal of
vaccinating 70 of the world by later
this year is any of this funding aimed
at jump starting global
vaccination efforts and can you talk a
little bit about why you're not on pace
is it for instance a supply problem or
is it a problem with
what what secretary lincoln called last
mile type stuff giving shots and arms to
borrow the language of the company that
is that is an undervalued part of it i
should say so i thank you for raising
that part of it so right now we've
shipped over around 440 million doses
and are continuing to aggressively share
around 10 million doses a week to the
world free of charge we're the first
country to buy doses for the sole
purpose of sharing them with the world
we also bought as you know a billion
doses um and secretary blinken i think
made those comments in part because he
wants to rally the world to do more uh
but a big part of our effort right now
um and and we're where we have seen
challenge is turning vaccines uh into
vaccination which means working closely
with our partners on the ground and
dealing with hyper-local issues
countries may be facing to increase
vaccination and this is a big part of
the focus of ambassador power and
usaid's global vaccination initiative
but part of it is is that shots in arms
component
deferring their us donations because the
capacity is the problem more than the
supply there there have been moments yes
where where countries are not able to
receive um the doses that we're able to
provide
go ahead thank you um
creating a gas tax holiday takes
legislation yes and i'm wondering
what are other things that the president
can do on his own
to mitigate i mean there isn't that much
it's a
ukrainian conflict
what else can he do by himself and in
terms of releasing
oil from the spr
have you made a determination of how
much
cost price that would offset in other
words what good does it do sure um
that's a good question and those are
assessments that our economic teams
constantly of course making um we did
see even the anticipation of the release
back in december helped lower the price
by about 10 cents um but
those assessments are are constantly
being made in terms of without a
decision being made which i know you're
not asking but just to be clear um there
are steps the president has taken
the strategic petroleum every time gas
prices are brought up shouldn't electric
vehicles be brought up too in response
world that's something we will continue
to do
because clearly we need to ensure that
the supply out in the global market is
meeting the demand and obviously
encouraging other companies to produce
more correct yes and that's been a part
of our effort even as we anticipate what
what impact there could be from an
invasion so as you know there's
obviously a difference between natural
gas shortages and the impact on home
heating which is largely a regional
issue but we have been still in europe
but we've been still working with
partners uh on that as well but also on
the supply of gas out in the market oh
well i should say man's a loser
president said that the invasion remains
distinctly possible some senior
administration said
a couple days ago that as soon as this
week is that still the timeline or has
anything shifted based on the kind of
mixed messages of the last couple days
we don't have a new assessment um as i
think you heard the president say um
it's there's a
distinct possibility but we don't have a
new assessment of a decision being made
either and then i know there's been
internal discussions about giving a
speech like the one the president had
today for some time um why today
and then the intent behind it the
president should really give a speech
just like this one the president gave a
speech like this one why did he do that
so why why today and why that uh range
of messages
you know philip phil i mean you all have
been covering this very closely the
potential of an invasion our diplomatic
engagements and there's no question the
american people have been consuming what
you have been reporting but i think we
felt and the president felt it was
important to uh be very clear and direct
uh with the american people about what
the impact could be on them uh what the
consequences would be uh what our values
are and why it is important to stand by
not just the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of a country
but also uh stand among our our allies
and partners around the world so it was
very important to him uh to lay out very
clearly uh what's the steps we've taken
the actions we're prepared to take
what's at stake for the united states
and the world and how this will impact
us here at home right in terms of why
today it wasn't based on obviously as
you saw a desire to put out a new policy
or based on
something new internally it was uh just
our the president's interest in and
feeling it was time to speak directly to
the american people about all of those
issues this last one on the first point
that you made there is there concern
either by the president or inside the
white house that perhaps
the understanding or support for kind of
traditional western alliances that have
been a pillar of the last 80 years is
waning or doesn't exist to the degree
that it used to
i think philbin
yeah no it's a good question i don't
have any data assessment of that but
we also are fully aware of the fact that
right now the american people are still
grappling with a pandemic they're
grappling with rising costs some two-ish
two big issues the president speaks to
quite frequently um and it was important
to him to be able to lay out clearly for
them what this uh you know potential
conflict potential invasion uh in in a
place that may feel far away and how
could impact them how that could impact
them and his engagement go ahead yeah
thank you jen uh president biden today
said there's 150 000 uh russian troops
in circling ukraine that appeared to be
a higher number than previously reported
i think 130 000 is how most recently uh
we've seen it characterized so was the
president confirming an actual
escalation of russian troops uh or
um why did he present a new number there
well i think over the last
dozen days or so we've seen a dramatic
acceleration and build up of troops um
and so the president said in his remarks
very carefully uh it's encircling
ukraine on the border and also in
belarus
and so i think he felt it was important
to give an assessment of where things
stand secondly regarding a gas tax
holiday you said quote all options
remain on the table there is right now a
bill from is the gas tax holiday just
like on one day if you buy gas there's
no tax i mean is it really that simple
that that's what they mean
we haven't made any decision about
additional steps at this point in time
good thanks jen two questions as you
mentioned earlier vice president harris
is headed to the munich security
conference this week does the president
plan to also send secretary blinken and
if so would a last-minute edition
suggest a different or perhaps reduced
or more limited role for vice president
harris at that conference
i don't think there's any plans to limit
or reduce the vice president's role at
the munich security conference or at the
global stage on a global stage she's
going to give a speech while she's there
and she is a vital and important
representative for the united states and
our values
and our intentions at this point
in in the world um but uh in terms of
plans for secretary blinken to attend or
not i i can check with the state
department see there are plenty of
leaders to meet with so
more bandwidth on a different note uh
the president continues to talk about
his buildback better plan he did so
today did a couple of events last week
what is the white house expectation at
this point about the future of that plan
is there any evidence of any sort of
forward movement for profits even on a
paired back version of that there
doesn't seem to be a lot of optimism or
action right now on capitol hill but can
you talk about what the white house
expectation is for that and why the
president continues to bring this up
well the president continues to bring it
up
it's constant coughing in that room you
guys noticing that people experience in
their daily lives as rising costs one of
the ways that we can address that is by
passing
legislation that will help lower costs
for americans whether it's child care or
health care or the cost of prescription
drugs and we can do that and fully pay
for it by making the tax system more
fair so what is encouraging to the
president um is that there is broad
support for lowering costs for the
american people in all of those
categories and for making the tax system
more fair and we are continuing to work
uh in lockstep and in partnership with a
range of senators and they're having
their own discussions about moving uh
these efforts forward
go ahead thank you very much jen uh one
question on asian americans and one
question on ukraine now asian americans
actually the usa gold medal winner
chloe kim revealed as an asian-american
according to ap quote she was tormented
online daily she said she was concealed
by the fear that her parents could be
killed whenever she heard the news about
another brutal passal
an asian person uncle actually under a
prison biden's watch in
2021 the anti-asian hate crimes
increased by
339 percent
it seems we don't see much action taken
by the white house and even in a press
briefing
the very last time you mentioned about
asian americans was let's make
so will the president take uh some
action or even just record a video like
what he did last year to raise the
awareness
well let me see first that um chloe kim
i'm obsessed with the olympics so i'm
just gonna give you a little biography
here but um she's 21 years old and she
made those comments which is incredibly
courageous and brave that she spoke out
about the fear she had the fear she has
for her family members and she's not the
only asian american to do that but she
is somebody who is now a double gold
medalist amazing um and so i just want
to take a moment to applaud her for her
courage in doing that i will say that
the president
has put in place a task force he has
hired a senior level staffer to be a
representative and be someone who can
speak to these threats and these
concerns and these fears felt by the
asian american community because there's
a number of steps we need to take and
continue to take to address and we've
seen this rise unfortunately because of
hate-filled rhetoric and language around
the uh the origins of the pandemic
and that is something that asian
americans across the country have been
feeling so i can just reiterate for you
that the president is absolutely
committed to continuing to speak out to
crack down to take steps um and again
would thank chloe kim for her courage
but go ahead on you let me i just have
to keep going because we gotta
look on ukraine jen um president biden
said that we should give diplomacy every
chance to succeed secretary blinken
after his call with foreign minister
lavrov said that there's a degree to
which this is like when i take live
calls where a bunch of people plan to
ask the exact same question but then
nobody has a backup so like they're
asking versions of the exact same
questions on ukraine well what's the
alternative if we don't leave the
open the window to diplomacy open
right i mean you know our objective
obviously is you heard the president say
today there is no threat the united
states is posing to russia to the
russian people there's no threat
that ukraine is posing to russia what
we're working to do here is leave a
forum for de-escalation for uh and
prevent a war and so for up to us the
door to diplomacy should always be open
and we should always look for
opportunities to de-escalate is there
any concern this turns into like a
frozen conflict basically where troops
just stay on the border and there's no
invasion but also no pullback well again
uh there's going to have to be a
continued dialogue and discussion but
russia not invading ukraine and not
risking uh and impacting uh the lives of
many many people in that country
including potentially american citizens
would certainly be a step we would
welcome
what americans should prepare for you
mentioned the threat of cyber attacks
the president mentioned that as well and
we know homeland security is previously
mentioned they've seen an uptick in
scanning on us critical critical
infrastructure and so on should
americans be prepared for a potential
russian cyber attack on critical us
infrastructure for other networks well i
would say even before we've been
discussing um the
the build up of troops at the border and
even before we've been discussing the
bellicose rhetoric
we have seen an uptick in cyber
activity
by malicious actors around the world
either those living in countries or the
countries themselves um and so that is
something i don't have any new threat or
new warning to pose today but that is
something we have certainly been uh
amping and increasing our focus on as an
as a threat that's emerging but has been
the case for the last several years can
you take your question on africa uh yeah
one second go ahead and then
jen just this hour lawmakers put out a
bipartisan statement warning president
putin i know you said from the podium
that the white house doesn't need
congress to pass the sanctions package
to implement your own sanctions package
but wouldn't it have sent a stronger
message if there had been an agreement
reached what message do you think it
sends to putin that all we got out of
congress was a statement
i think president putin knows very
clearly because he's heard it directly
from president biden's mouth that if he
invades uh if he invades ukraine that
there will be crippling sanctions and we
don't need congress to act in order to
do that and when will the president make
a decision
on
any new energy policies to impact prices
at the pump because even without an
invasion prices have risen beyond where
they were before the emergency reserve
released back in november you're right
and the president is very focused on
making sure we're doing everything we
can to lower the cost
for americans in any way it hits them
whether it's prices at the pump or when
you go buy a pound of meat
or wherever it may be so we're
continuing to assess and he's continuing
to look at options i don't have a
prediction of of any decision though
go ahead
i'll i'll go to you after simon quinn
switching topics entirely the president
is headed later this week to ohio he
said that he'd like to be out in
communities with people yeah frequently
how often would he like to be out there
per week what do you guys remember every
day well
but when he says that what is your
anticipation is he looking to travel two
three days a week and when would you
expect that to ramp up i you know i
think you can expect that to increase
around the state of the union and after
um and
uh i think we are constrained by a
couple of things including the cr
funding but also the fact that there is
a whole lot going on in the world um
even though he can be president anywhere
uh he also has a responsibility to
sometimes be in the white house uh or
oftentimes be in the white house so but
he's looking forward to getting out
there more in the coming weeks does he
have anywhere specific that he hasn't
been yet or places that he hasn't been
that he feels frequently enough that
he'd really like to get back to
uh good question i i would venture to
guess that he has probably been nearly
everywhere given he ran for president a
couple times and vice president
as president i don't have any prediction
of states or at readout of states that
he's looking forward to going to but
yeah
who cares
traveling around the country blue states
red states uh across the gamut go ahead
okay okay simon i'll go to you go ahead
okay thank you thank you it's been three
months so if you can allow me to ask two
questions
that the president spoke with prime
minister bihar
of ethiopia on january 10th it's been
almost a month now more than a month in
that court took place and the who
yesterday released a statement saying
that the state don't have access to the
tea grave region for humanitarian access
because the government is not allowing
them to have fuel so is the president
still interested in anything else apart
from ukraine
uh of course he is um the president this
guy always asks pretty aggressive
questions i've noticed
and he is responsible for not just
what's happening which is fine so what's
happening domestically let me give you
an update or a comment from here we're
hopeful that recent steps taken by the
government of ethiopia and other actors
might open a path to resolving the
conflict over the last month the prime
minister has taken steps to promote
dialogue release political prisoners and
enable expanded delivery of medical
supplies in the tigray region we
continue to have serious concerns about
the humanitarian situation ethiopia and
we are focused on working with our
parties uh with all parties to end the
source of the suffering the military
conflict go ahead karen
president salinki tomorrow or is calling
for a day of unity a national holiday
tomorrow in ukraine his message for the
last couple of days if not longer has
been don't panic to ukrainians does the
administration have concerns that
zielinski and ukrainian leaders have not
adequately prepared the ukrainian people
for a russian invasion
well i'm not going to speak to that what
i can speak to is what we feel our role
in responsibility is which is to provide
a range of information about uh what we
see at the border uh what we see russia
preparing and our assessment of what
impact that could be every leader makes
their own decisions do you have an
update on the humanitarian assistance
that the us is talking with european
allies should that happen and ukrainian
people need that sure i know we uh
secretary blinken made an announcement i
believe it was yesterday about um
additional
um assistance let me just see if i have
any more details on it and here and if
not i will get that to you shortly after
the briefing karen let me just see
um
let's see here
let me get you i can get you let's see
last night so we we did offer we just
announced sorry a sovereign loan
guaranteed ukraine of up to one billion
dollars to bolster ukraine's economy
amidst pressure resulting from russia's
military build up this build on the
three billion in sovereign loan
guarantees we issued to ukraine between
2014 and 2016
we've also committed more security
assistance to ukraine in the last year
than at any point in history 650
million and we also announced we're
launching a new partnership fund for
resilient ukraine with our european uh
with our allies and partners um to
include to continue to expand on that
the last thing is we the export-import
bank has made available three billion
dollars in support for projects in
ukraine and the development finance
corporation has a current investment
portfolio in ukraine of approximately
800 million dollars across more than a
dozen projects so we've obviously
provided a range of assistance which we
will continue to build on go ahead uh
jen will vice president harris be
meeting with president zlinski when
she's in munich i don't have anything on
her planned meetings at this point in
time i expect we'll have more as we get
a little bit closer and and i expect
they'll do a preview call from her team
as well and then an olympics question
yeah does the administration have any
reaction to the ioc's decision to allow
russian figure skater and what's her
name camila balila to continue competing
in the olympics after joking
uh well i would point you to the uh
statement made by the u.s olympic and
paralympic committee who opposed the
decision made in beijing saying it
appears to be another chapter in the
systemic and pervasive disregard for
clean sport by russia but these were
independent decisions made by the u.s
anti-doping agency and court of
arbitration for sport we don't have any
additional comment from here i would
point you again to the u.s olympic
committee
so the u.s energy information
administration shows data that russian
oil being imported in the u.s has been
increasing over the past year in may of
2021 it was the most on record now the
president said he wants to use all tools
to keep gas prices down is it is he
looking at temporary things to keep gas
prices down should there be a russian
invasion or is there any consideration
in reversing some of the policies and
going back to increasing u.s energy
independence
uh i don't have anything to uh detail
for you including in terms of what he is
considering but our overarching
objective is to in decrease the impact
on american consumers and increase the
impact on uh russian leaders we talked
about the boycott um on the republicans
of the fed nominees does the white house
support allowing four of the five
nominees to go through and then dealing
with sarah broome raskin later
again we are working with uh with uh
chairman brown to move all five nominees
forward uh go ahead right there go ahead
yeah thanks jen um do you have any
update on maybe steps the white house is
taking in the event that the trucker
protesting in canada heads to the u.s
and also especially to d.c around the
time of the state of the union
well we our department of homeland
security team has been assessing and i
gave an update last week that they also
increased support uh federal support uh
around the super bowl when there were
those reports i would note the super
bowl did move forward and there was no
um no halting of that so that is a
positive development uh as well but we
are constantly assessing any impact for
people asking me to speak to destiny i
did just reach out to him on discord and
he says
he's been playing a lot of games so he
doesn't know if he's caught up and i was
like oh i just wanted to check in about
how things were going in miami but he
doesn't seem to want to be on
unfortunately late last year has he at
all reviewed the report yet and taken a
position on it uh it wasn't uh it wasn't
i just remind everyone it wasn't
recommendations it was a broad
assessment from across the uh gambit of
um uh scholars from from all ends of the
political spectrum uh
who were looking at a range of historic
issues as it relates to the court the
president has been reviewing that but i
don't have anything to uh read out for
you on that front thing i wanted to ask
you was about voting rights the
president signed this expansive
executive order a year ago on voting
i believe susan rice put out an on it in
september or october um could you
provide an update on what agencies are
doing we're going to start beginning
seeing elections as soon as next month
um i believe that's in texas but other
states are going to start to have them
yes i do have a lot on this not in front
is that ryan grimm in the press briefing
room by what what happened to him i
caught a couple clips of the uh
hill rising thing now
and it's crazy what has happened over
there like it's so obviously absurd and
it's it's just
who is watching that stuff sid
but if you look at it past examples
where i think it was back in the 90s
where if you went to the dmv to renew
your driver's license they would offer
you the opportunity to register to vote
you know stuff like that but let me see
if we can get you something and anyone
else who's interested after the briefing
okay we'll do one more and then we'll
wrap it up go ahead thank you so much
one on china one in afghanistan first of
all i guess they're not calling on ryan
graham huh of us rhetoric on the russia
ukraine crisis calling it hyping up the
possibility of warfare saying the u.s is
clamoring for block confrontation
confrontation what does the white house
make of this rhetoric are you going to
take any action against either through
talk or other means and what do you make
of this closeness between mossville and
beijing
well i would say that the first the
meeting that they had a couple of weeks
ago reflects an approach both countries
have already taken for some time which
is to move closer together we know and
we've said before but china's not in a
position to compensate russia for their
economic
losses and we have tools to deploy if we
see foreign companies including those in
china trying to backfill sanctions
you know i i would say our overarching
view though is that if russia chooses to
move forward um it will cost china and
how it's viewed in the eyes of europe
and the world and that's something for
them to assess um we
are trying to prevent a war here
that is why we are putting information
out and why we are engaging with the
global community wow how do you respond
to afghans who are critical of the
executive order that proposes to split
the the frozen afghan money they say
that you know they weren't involved in
the 911 attacks so why are they getting
less of these funds that they're
entitled to
well i would say that first um
you know in order for just let me start
with the fact that um this is one step
in the process no funds can be
transferred until the courts make a
ruling
what the president was trying to do was
enable certain us-based assets belonging
to afghanistan's central bank to be used
to benefit the afghan people otherwise
it would have been held right and that
from money wouldn't have been going and
so that that's why we saw and he took a
proactive step to facilitate access to
3.5 billion of those assets for the
benefit of the afghan people and
afghanistan's future um more than as you
know uh many u.s victims of terrorism
including the relatives of victims who
died in the september 11th terrorist
attacks have have brought claims against
the taliban and are pursuing these
assets in federal court um so more than
35.5 billion in assets are going to
remain in the united states and are
subject to the ongoing litigation but i
think it's important for people to know
and understand is he took this proactive
step to sign the executive order in an
effort to try to provide some of this
funding to the afghan people
the courts have to rule in order for it
to happen
3.5 billion dollars right the court that
has it has to the courts have to rule in
order for any of the funding to move
forward i believe it's my understanding
he's making clear that he believes that
half of the funding should go to the
afghan people to uh for humanitarian
purposes thanks everyone
will president biden meet in person with
the russian president i think i answered
that question a little bit earlier man
just the same questions being asked
multiple times which is kind of uh
kind of kind of weird um
let me see here
people asking about moderating you can
email info at davidpakman.com about that
uh let's listen to a couple of
voicemails because i just have so many
let's uh see if we can hit a few of the
highlights here's whitney
so i took another look at the enneagrams
and i realized that um
only the enneagram that's described as
the third right goes the number okay
eric from mass
hey david eric from math there's not
going to be any advertising or uh
sponsorship if you don't tell everybody
that you walked him right into getting
aids
the vaccine does not cause aids and our
sponsorships are doing just fine i want
to say thank you to trisha northstar
grandpa simpson youngest milo wild and
wookie jack for the twitch prime
subscriptions also thanks to luke martin
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama your new member
number 21. let's continue with
voicemails
hi david um thank you for your show i
just listened to this segment regarding
the
milestones for when you should stop mass
mandates and i just wanted to add that i
think it would be helpful to include
the fact that children under five are
not yet vaccinated as a potential
milestone or just conversation i'm aware
that those
children getting the virus are also less
likely to have severe disease absolutely
true
the cat is out of the bag the horse is
out of the stables
you can't unring a bell
the genie is out of the bottle the mask
mandates are dropping and it's not
there's nothing i can say to change it
the mask mandates are dropping it's just
very clear that that's the direction
um things are going
so i found islamic philosophy
and islamic theology
in the myers-briggs
as
um infj i have not found that here's
eric from mass again
hey david it's clara from math i just
want to know if you have a comment um
reuters endorses ivor maxim reuters is
not a medical organization it's not true
that reuters has endorsed ivermectin but
reuters is a news organization uh let's
go now to uh billy harrison
hello mr david tackman
my name is billy harrison i am a
republican
and i support donald trump to the
fullest
and i bet you
thank you give me your information
whatever i bet you
uh hundred dollars thousand dollars
whatever you want to bet that you will
not
answer these questions
on your youtube channel okay
replying
[Music]
the questions that i'm about to ask
bring it on
okay yeah i'm ready first of all
i watch you when you
do the
live donald trump bingo [ __ ] okay you
think you're making a point no i'm not
it's just fun the bingo thing is just
fun there's it's we're just having a
good time that's all it is
little
fan club and your little democratic
colleague
tells y'all because he says
some of the things he says in his old
rallies that's not a big deal but you
don't for some reason whenever he says
i've had the lowest black unemployment
boom in a common economy
uh lowest unemployment out of really
every race
um
what's the question dude like there's
not even a question there it's crazy all
right let's go back to whitney
i have a book recommendation for you um
it's called the cosmic serpent not
interested let's go to eric from mass
hey david eric from math i just want to
know if you had a comment on the
pentagon research papers that were
released on the vaccines proving that
graphene oxide is in them
um okay that also didn't happen uh let's
go back to whitney
so well i don't understand
whoops okay and that one got cut off
another one from whitney
so i also looked up um
what people sound like uh
to be
entertaining as far as like selfless
or thankful people right uh here's uh
troy york
uh basically uh falsely gabriel is
correct
okay that's uh that's i'm gonna nope
right out of there back to whitney
i am so excited about megan and harry
maybe moving to california okay back to
eric from mass
hey david it's eric from mass um just
wondering how some of you haven't warned
everybody about uh aids and the
vaccines the vaccine does not cause aids
back to troy york
how are these attackmen
uh i couldn't help to notice that okay
come barely audible let's try another
one oh and uh this is cecil brewster
calling back okay another fake name
cecil brewster
mr packman
um one thing i have to agree with you
um the caller you had
about joe logan on a recent video
no vineyard
owning
elite snob
is going to talk any sense into joe
rogan
nor will most of joe rogan's fans which
i am included in which are growing man i
don't know what he's talking about back
to whitney
so
if the
person who
thought that like feelings should
dictate somebody's life
was hailing
a country like iran being like that's
the smarter individuals
okay back to billy harrison
david pac-man pretty sure you know who
this is
me and you man debate live on your show
i don't give you my number
email
your your audience wants to see it i've
read the
comments
yeah call in any time okay i told you
back to troy york
david pacman
the democrat party is the mafia
party
okay and then back to whitney
a blank voicemail from whitney it's all
day like this here's another one
so um what i noticed that is the
government started like joining in on
some of like the newcomers that came in
here and
instead of like raising red flags that
like our country doesn't want people
like hard workers and stuff they're
starting to gang up
with like our
fathers and mothers okay do you guys
want one more billy harrison or are we
done what do you guys think one more
billy harrison or just call it on
voicemails i don't know
one more okay here's one more billy
harrison
david pac-man this is billy harrison
again the chaotic caller as you
call me
uh
you know i
i really didn't appreciate that too much
hey by the way guys for people thinking
i'm going to run out i have 839 fresh
voicemails for you guys 839.
okay
i'm a man's man i know you don't know
what that is
pretty sure your democratic friends
laugh at that i don't care
uh
but that was my four-month-old
coin
in the background not my two i have a
two-year-old as well
he was probably playing
uh
the kids do what they do
right
another thing like i said
menu live debate on your show facts
it's funny like the people most
desperate to debate don't understand
like a debate isn't you just call in and
insult me a debate would be like okay
i believe vaccines
cause covid
you believe they don't
let's cite sources you know like they
don't even understand what it means to
debate you know he just wants to call
and go oh wait but when you do the trump
bingo it's bad it's like okay it's not
really a debate you know it's it's very
very strange
um
all right i want to say thank you to asf
klopp's chief boris greater candle
bowflex man for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 25 and also
vincent jenner who just signed up on my
website using the coupon code obama
obama and we will ban men that will do
it for today's stream we will be back
later this week
and we will be live live live with the
joe biden
state of the union address it's going to
be a very strong stream long and wide i
would say
we'll see everybody tomorrow don't do
anything i wouldn't do in the meantime